a nurse accused of sexual assault named
in a lawsuit against sunrise hospital
and we are learning the same nurse faced
a previous allegation thank you for
joining us at five i'm brian loftis i'm
denise valdez our i-team broke this
story last week and now our david charns
is learning more about what that
previous allegation involved david
denise i do want to warn you the details
of what i'm about to relay are sexual in
nature a second woman claiming she was
sexually assaulted while in the care of
ricardo medeiros at sunrise hospital two
years ago according to a lawsuit
medeiros sexually assaulted that woman
who was in her late 40s repeatedly by
touching her breasts we are not
identifying her because she is a sexual
assault victim who has not yet publicly
spoken about her claim documents filed
in court also say the patient quote had
no means of escape due to her physical
condition and the positioning of
mederos's body documents indicating both
mederos and sunrise deny these claims
metro did investigate but that case was
closed due to lack of evidence mederos
has no criminal record here in nevada he
has been ordered though not to practice
while this latest case moves forward but
he is facing charges in a second case
that one involving 54 year old catherine
burnett who right here right here last
night told you about her allegations now
she alleges madero sexually assaulted
her and performed a sex act in front of
her at sunrise while a patient there
last month
people need to know that these things
are happening in these hospitals
and women need to share it women need to
speak up
and fight against it mederos right now
on house arrest today an attorney
entering a not guilty plea on his behalf
in court now sunrise just got back to me
pointing out in a statement that mederos
was not charged in that 2019 incident
and they reiterate they contact police
when necessary i'm david charns 8 news
now